модератор образотворче мистецтво
даність ук лілія федорівна
доброго дня всім властивим я відразу такий
у нас правді сила ми програми ватина як
конструктивно така США вимагаючи канай
менше таких цих кардинальних змін їжі
на рахунок чого про подавалися розван
теж ти дітей ти туди таким же одне води
ну не одну над цією а2 та друга за брат і
я озвучую ти що я
що я можу цю інформацію та один одного
на що поскаржитися наші коментатори
наші дописуються ти че на уроках
образотворче вийде і мають по ви не про
зігнутий і на відповідай навичці кільки з
теоретичного матеріалу зазначу ще виду
то цільову ділянку на практичну
роботу на емоційно розван теж не
топ-топ печа стільки дасте проти нього
народ want пожвавити йому тину та кольору
терапія та арт-терапія та знайомства
зірковими техніками та графіки новачки
моторики руки і так далі топ топ і де
пропозиція максимально спростить і теорію
так просто виживання і по серединному від
виживання на уроках літаюче блюдце
тенові розумі на прощу та димова
авансцени було цього диска вам до
заучування кіфу star minipci зрозуміти і 3
щодо рекомендувалися так
максималізму взагалі б не домагалися від
м і забрати відвертаюсь трудового
нальчани
я велів край так